i was freaking out a little bit
i was just along for the ride i had no
expectations
[Music]
you start
chad super likes me on tinder oh my
goodness uh if you swiped right yeah
yeah i did super like but it's
interesting because i didn't have to
super like you because i had an account
where i knew who liked me
so he was it was fate
we met at um a queer halloween party for
women so she was wearing like a leather
jacket and wings it was cold it was an
outdoor party she's like i'm an angel
duh i was like i thought you were
lucifer i don't know
how did we first meet him do you want to
start sure okay so i had just moved to
la i found it through instagram this
initiative called queer field day one of
like the first games that we played was
queer family feud and one of the
questions was it was the worst character
the worst character from the l word and
both of us agreed that it was alice
hands down but we bonded over that and
then once the game was over i kept
talking yeah i got home i was like
laying in bed and i get a dm from her on
my instagram she was like are you still
here
i was like no it's like don't forget you
said you were gonna hang out this
weekend
and you were like so you should
definitely just come meet me and my
family in boston i was very nervous
because you meeting my family was the
only other time besides my ex that i was
introducing someone to my family and you
were so
new like to me only three weeks of
knowing you and my spanish skills has to
be on par that was a test
there were a lot of thoughts going on
and i felt like we really bonded over
the fact that you know we were both
taiwanese and started talking about how
we grew up and our childhood and i just
remember thinking this person has so
much energy
i was so drawn to that you were just so
excited and bubbly and it was really
cute how did you feel when i started
yeah
nervous but then we hugged and then the
nerves just dissipated
mentally i was confused
because i thought i would be more
anxious but it was like a calming
feeling like wow how do i feel so
relaxed and so into this person
she told me she had two kids i said i
know it's not the same but i have three
cats i was like wow you're that lesbian
i was mostly intimidated um really yeah
oh my gosh you were like totally just
owning your space and i was like wow
that girl is gorgeous and then i saw in
your little name tag that you were
pansexual and i was like
hmm
maybe she would be interested in
my flavor of human
[Music]
a big part of what helped me feel
encouraged introducing someone to my
family
was imagining how their interactions
would go
and it was really great to see you just
like barge into my cousin's house
speaking in spanish yeah she was like
who are you here with
it was right before thanksgiving and so
she offered to bring me a plate and i
canceled like the day of because i was
really hungover
and she was like it's okay i'll just
come and drop off the plate and like and
i was like and i'll bring you some
pedialyte letting her think that like i
already had pedialyte but i actually
stopped at the store on my way to her
place to get pedialyte it was my
birthday and
bee went out of her way to make it
really special for me
i just wanted to spend the night in and
not go out and she wrote me a poem and
gave me a cupcake do you remember the
poem
i
do not
i don't i don't have her poems memorized
but i have them all in a notebook
this is so embarrassing
i turned her down
and i was like i don't know if i'm
emotionally available right now and she
was so great about it she was like
cool i'm so happy to be your friend that
works and i was like not
never just not right now yeah that was
true it's just that like not never meant
four days later
we did the very typical first lesbian
date thing of like yeah time warp yeah
the world disappeared and we just kind
of fell into each other that's great
so and here we are five months and
change later
what date are we counting
super like date oh then six months seven
months
seven eightish months you were very open
and clear about the things that you
liked and wanted and even on the things
that we didn't align you were honest
about that
and we're
doing what we know we want to do to see
if there is a true possibility going
from this so if you guys liked any of
our super cute stories check out this
clip of the meet cute from my fake
boyfriend sharing food is one of my
favorite things
the cherry mill with someone from a
different country someone who's language
you don't know and still communicate
because food is a universal language
when you make someone something
delicious to eat you're communicating
that you care
you're sharing your love
[Music]
okay
enough of that
let's make mezza
hey jessica hi rafi i like your hair
thank you you're good thanks this is all
lovely
you're andrew right
uh yeah you're bernie's ride he talks
about you all the time
oh does he yeah
so uh he finally convinced you to come
to class
no i
yeah he did because he knows how bad of
a cook i am
i actually tried to make him some
breakfast one time and then we ended up
at urging care
that was you yeah
here let me help you
thanks
so you want to take your left hand and
make it a little bit like a claw protect
your knuckles okay and then
put your hand up a little higher on the
knife a little higher
there you go
then
boom
just like a seesaw
[Music]
so
[Music]
you